contact tracing teams are working fast
this weekend trying to find people who
may have crossed paths with anyone
infected with the fast spreading omicron
variant after first being reported in
south africa the coronavirus strain has
made its way to at least 11 states
federal health officials are urging the
public to vaccinate and to stay calm as
they try to learn more about the
particular strain of this virus tom
hansen is here with the very latest tom
good morning hey there michelle good
morning to you the biggest question is
whether current available vaccines will
prevent severe cases spread by the
omicron variant so far the handful of
known cases in the u.s have been
reported by health officials as mild and
invaccinated people but with so few
cases there's not enough evidence yet on
what to expect from omicron it's still
cases from the delta variant that have
officials attention
coveted cases driven by the delta
variant are rising averaging 96 000 new
cases a day and hitting hard in the
upper midwest to new england new
hampshire led the country in new cases
per capita last week 99.9 percent of
cases in the country right now are from
the delta variant when it comes to the
omicron variant health officials are
counseling calm we are equipped and
prepared to fight the omicron variant
head on there's every reason to believe
that if you get vaccinated and boosted
then you would have at least some degree
of cross protection
very likely against severe disease
even against the omicron variant but
omicron spreads twice as fast as the
delta variant and this week mild cases
of the strain first identified in south
africa popped up in multiple states
including maryland where governor larry
hogan had just announced an aggressive
partnership to find covet cases fast the
state entered into agreements with both
johns hopkins
and the university of maryland to more
than double our already aggressive
real-time variant surveillance for
international travelers they will be
required to take a coveted test one day
before boarding a flight to the u.s from
a country where omicron has been
detected and once they arrive many
airports have on-site testing personally
i don't have a problem with that if they
make it available at the airport if they
make it free and hopefully quick then
yeah i don't i don't have any vision so
far 34 countries have identified cases
with the omicron strain now is not the
time to relax we're seeing this variant
of concern and the way to address
variants is to slow covet transmission
and we do that through vaccination we do
that through masking and from dr anthony
fauci get vaccinated and get boosted
now the new variant has prompted health
officials in some places to revive
contact tracing operations that were put
in place in the early days of the
pandemic they're hoping to better
understand how the omicron variant
spreads and whether it can avoid
vaccines jeff tom thank you very much